chacun d'entre eux va se présenter va
présenter l'émission fera dire bonjour
et pmp en fait commencé en quoi vous moi
je commençais en arabe très bien vous
décidément vous êtes beaucoup cette lan
vous dire bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans
tp voilà je vais dire marc avait marre a
bavé comme athée pmp aramis à me lâcher
elle va le dire en quelle langue
portugaise alors je regarde je dis même
vîmes d'eau m
naoto caisse mais opter les visas ou
alors là déjà qu'en france on a un peu
de mal donc là vous savez dans gilmore
l'italien s'est pratiquement mal ma
langue maternelle
mes parents sont en italie mais vous
êtes tout de tous les pays bas en italie
en italien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mehdi et italiens je deviens quelqu'un
qui ait pris part au japon
l'escroquerie envoyé des lots à totti
tout chaud pasta amis tosti j'ai précisé
jma excuse j'ai omis de préciser
l'italie du sud
tout le monde ne parle pas l'itc monde
pailleté c'est une arnaque
maxime guinea donc c'est en quoi vous en
espagnol vous parle espagnol couramment
en bocaux ou d'espacé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait au labo nationale chasse alors
quand c'est cyril vous fait l'effort
d'apprendre vous lâchez votre fils vous
plaire aux labos nas notre chef bien à
notre caisse mais pointe au passeport
qu'est la télévision' s nada mas qu'à la
télévision alors venez donc dire
bienvenue dans tpm paix et donc vous
m'avez fait une tartine encore non
parquet la télévision s n'a pas masqué
la télévision d'état télé mais ce que je
vais demander de faire ça non mais
c'était le petit bonus au foyer c'est
vraiment le fardeau de la banque vous
faire alors alors encouragez-les en
hommage à nos frères canadiens je fais
en québécois jeunes à la géniale
on va attendre un peu quand même
difficile combat on va pas s'emballer un
bonsoir bienvenue dans tpm tient alors
assez bien
[Applaudissements]
euh non il dépresseurs les
sous-vêtements honnêtement si nos amis
canadiens nous regardent et désolé pour
eux
et même si nos amis suisses nous regarde
on a un petit mix entre du lac son bel
accent suisse tout court versez y est
j'ai essayé à la mamie alors qu'isabelle
alors le vieux france ô
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après c'est sûr mais français moi alors
encore que l'on programmes en allemand
alors je men et jetons voilà alors tous
patrick comme emma 9 rbds et 1 et
chevelure de tous les deux astres qu'on
a vu c'est moi je vais me disch lines a
pris ça avec ma faute c'est mademoiselle
ou madame même on peut dire matin je
sais pas dire qu'en mer
[Musique]
c'est une bonne vibe il a dit mi
chowdhary pas le retenir
je sais lire je suis dit recueillons
c'est en ami comme en découlent en avant
ni moi quoi y en a nous ment des
couillons elle si tu sais face à
connacht au alors je suis ravi de vous
savez tant mieux je suis sûr et because
you you international et là je suis la
première à avoir répondu
et donc j'ai le droit à cette langue la
mer donc en gros c'est le plus facile
pour un goût des benjamines goudé one
world wind touch my swing de chouettes
de touche pas trop mal au mal à avouer
produits de taux
[Applaudissements]